[Music]
this is star talk
i'm neil degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist
and today we're going to do star talk
cosmic queries which continues to be a
fan favorite in our format on the topic
today is science
history specializing in
the a part of human history though when
nobody thinks any science happened at
all
me included and that would be medieval
history okay that is the like the
the benchmark for anyone's concept of
where no science
touched anybody's life i got matt
kirschen here to help me out as my
co-host
matt hey neil co-host of probably
science
and tell me when will that show ever
graduate to be
actually science it's never going to get
there neil we got the closest one year
on the show
so if i come back on the show a couple
more times then it can be turned into
likely science it's tending towards
science but
it's definitely science it'll never
actually reach it
okay well that gives you freedoms sort
of in your conversational latitude
there so who we have in studio or
actually he's not quite in studio he's
at his home base in cambridge
england where he serves as
one of the academic scholars there we've
got
seb faulk seb welcome to star talk thank
you very much for inviting me
seb you're the first seb i've ever met
so that's got to be short for something
other than
seborrhea i presume sebastian yeah
sebastian very nice it's a mouthful in
the uk we give it four syllables
sebastian
but uh over there i think you only give
it three right it's sebastian
sebastian yeah we just yeah i will just
go with sam famous
lobster i think really so uh
is that right i don't have any seafood
that shares in the little moment jealous
oh sebastian yes no he wasn't a lobster
he was a he was a hermit crab
was he a helmet crap i apologize yes
totally that's why you have to shell
with him uh you didn't you didn't notice
that
yeah hermit crabs inhabit other shells
that they didn't create that's why
they're called hermit yeah yeah
so he's a crab not a lobster and but
that means
they taste the same all i know is
darling it's better down where it's
wetter
don't get me started about uh her song
where she longs for being on
the ground and i'm thinking look you
have the entire freaking ocean to swim
in
are there two things you can miss fire
and sunlight
but everything else she sings about she
wants to walk on streets it's like
no you can swim in three dimensions like
shut up
compose a different song why it's great
to be in the ocean
but that's not what the point of
that's another episode we'll talk about
the science of the little mermaid
but uh where this is cosmic queries
science history so
seb you're a historian and your
specialty
is science in the latter middle
ages that's right and i didn't know
it was divided up that precisely what
what's going on what's the
what's the beginning middle and ladder
what are the years associated with that
well the middle ages people normally say
when we're talking about europe
is from about 500 to 1500 a.d
of our thousand years a thousand years
quite a lot happens in that time
well that includes the time of um the
golden age of
of islam where science was happening
back between 800 and 1100 yeah yeah
it's problem it's a problem for
historians because the word medieval
means in the middle the time in the
middle and so
the very word is a slander the very word
is a way of saying yeah
that bit we don't really care about the
bit between this one good bit and this
other good bit and the first good bit
was
ancient greece and rome and the other
good bit was the renaissance
and people in the renaissance said okay
we're great we are recovering the wisdom
of the ancients
and so everything that came between us
we can just ignore
we frogged over them yes because they
had nothing but plagues
exactly exactly so uh it's defined but
just to be clear so you got a phd
from the university of cambridge and
what was the title of your thesis
the title of my thesis oh gosh um was
uh improving instruments equatorial
astrolabes and the practices of monastic
astronomy in late medieval england
so you're talking behind me you've got
some astronomy in you
very oh yes oh yeah no i i i focus on
astronomy
like they keep keep looking up and
that's what people were doing in the
middle ages
excellent excellent okay and of course
but this year you released a book
either the the light ages clever title i
see what you did there yeah
clever title the surprising story of
medieval science so i love it i love it
so
keep so tell me again so later middle
ages is what
so uh it depends on what you're looking
at but what i study is mainly
from about the 1100s to about the
1400s uh 12th century to about the 15th
century and focusing in particular
on the 14th century which was called
famously the calamitous 14th century
because that's when they had the black
death and they had 100 years war between
england and france and
a whole lot of horrible things happen
but at the same time as all those
horrible and exciting battles and plays
and things
were going on there were people looking
up at the stars people investigating
nature people asking questions yeah you
see no
we just think you're we all just think
you're lying so
yeah this whole show will be you
trying to convince us all that we we're
that our understanding of that period is
just
flawed yeah because that is i'm i'm sure
this is the
focus of your work and your book because
i
definitely have the impression that for
roughly a thousand years everything was
just made of mud
that's that's why i felt i had to write
this book and it's also why i wrote the
book and the way i did because
what i don't do is say you've got to
take my word for it because he's going
to take my word for it
i walk people through so i say this is
how you multiply roman numerals it's not
as difficult
as you might think this is what you can
work out just by looking up at the
heavens and
figuring out the calendar and the phases
of the moon and so on and just step by
step
trying to get people from zero to
advanced medieval astronomer which of
course is not as advanced
not to put too much in your lap in one
instant but uh in my notes it says here
you
uh you you focus on a monk named john
of westwick that's right and why is he
supposed to i actually never heard of
him
well that's kind of the point in a way
that uh
so many people the point of your book is
that i've never heard of him
in a way the point of my belonging
nobody nobody has ever heard of him and
that doesn't matter
um the point is that so many histories
of science are told
as kind of parades of great men and it
is so often men in these stories where
it's like a lone genius who solved this
problem and then
another lone genius comes along 100
years later and we all know that science
doesn't work like that it definitely
doesn't work like that now
and it never did in the past either you
know there's so many people whose names
are just not widely known who made their
own contributions and who
made kind of incremental improvements in
our understandings of everything
and so i wanted to tell the story of
medieval science through an unknown
figure precisely to avoid
falling into this trap of saying you
know this is a famous person who made
this
this contribution so very clever now now
you're i mean as
a tool to to get in on the subject and
to get it out
get in and out on the subject so before
i get you to explain
what it is we all don't know about that
period let me just throw something else
in your lap
as i understand it the 14th century is
the only 100 year span
in the history of our species where the
population of humans in the world was
less at the end of that century than it
was at the beginning of that century
so is that true i i couldn't
say for certain but it is entirely
plausible to me because the black death
uh killed somewhere between
40 and 50 of the population wherever it
wherever it hit and um recent research
has shown that it spread much more
widely than historians have previously
thought a lot of new genetic research
showing how it spread into africa spread
you know right across asia
um the americas of course untouched by
it but apart from that you know eurasia
and africa or at least um northern
africa
and and down into the middle of africa
were all hit by the black death and it
was okay so
now i think now tell me what's great
about this time
okay i'm not here to say that
we should all wish that we lived in the
middle ages but what i am here to say
is that if you think that uh everybody
was stupid in the past or that people
didn't achieve anything or that nobody
was interested in the world around
them then then that's wrong because
people have always been interested in
the world around them people have always
looked up and even at times of great
famine or hardship or
conflict um people have found time to
investigate the world around them and
people have
asked interesting questions and so what
i'm trying to do is reclaim the word
medieval a little bit and make people
look again at this period
and look at the achievements and the
interests of the times
uh including inventing really
interesting astronomical instruments
like those astrolades uh you can see
there behind me
and also kind of asking questions about
nature and fitting nature
into the framework of their
understanding of the universe which
for christians was of course a universe
created by god
and so it's a different understanding to
the one we have today but still
uh you know scientific in its own terms
so how does science
gurgle up under the forces of mysticism
and miracles and magic of the time
it's a big question uh the
the the basics
the legend of king arthur is in this
period as well correct uh well no so
arthur
i mean was arthur a real person this is
a kind of an open question
um lots of legends spread around this
time and this is a time when people are
really into myths and legends
um but the point is that people look
around them and they
they need uh a world that operates in a
predictable coherent way just as well
that's what i'm getting at
the king arthur had merlin right yeah so
merlin was sort of the closest thing
anyone could reference
who knew about chemistry or biology or
the the natural world
and i just wonder if his knowledge
would manifest in other people's
impressions as magic
even if he was just doing science well
magic was certainly something that
interested people and there was a whole
category that was called natural magic
and natural magic is essentially
what you can't really explain like
magnetism
uh or some um features
of uh plants that seem kind of
surprising but also things that we might
now say
were fraudulent um so astrology kind of
shades into natural magic
basically this is a world in which
miracles can and do
happen but the whole point of a miracle
is it doesn't happen every day
so while you're waiting for your miracle
to come along you still have to live in
the world as it is
day to day so just as people would go to
their churches
or go to cathedrals and and pilgrimage
shrines and pray for a miracle to be
healed from whatever disease was
afflicting them
while they were waiting for that miracle
they would be treated by healers
often often priests who would treat them
according to the best standards of the
medicine of the day so it's not one
thing or the other
like you can still look up at the stars
and
make predictive models of you know when
the when there's going to be an eclipse
or when the planets are going to be in
conjunction
while also believing that those planets
are going to affect your health and the
weather
in ways that we today would call um
incorrect
so i'm going to ask i'm going to ask a
question for matt okay
uh matt that's what i'm asking on your
behalf okay so back then
did they also have court jesters who if
they weren't funny they would be
killed in principle yeah yes
i don't think always but i i think you
would probably i think you might get
fired before you were killed but you
know
a job's a job well
what are your other options right i know
my comedian friends
your mobility is low tell them it's
it's cash on the night and there's a
meal and they'll risk getting killed
afterwards
little risk they'll risk it okay that's
meritocracy
i was just wondering if you know because
comedians who do really well on stage
people say oh they killed
i'm wondering if that's just part of the
culture of kill or be killed in that
environment
um foreign it is all the same language
you die on stage when it goes badly it's
very wow
yeah there's some truth in it it's quite
brutal the language that's used
so so um so seb give me some concrete
examples
of so jewels of science that that
girled up in this period that none of us
would have imagined
the way that medieval people looked at
science was that they were trying to
build on the ideas of of the ancients so
some of the stuff that you might have
heard about people like aristotle or
archimedes
eratosthenes who worked out the uh
the the conference of the globe um
these are ideas that are picked up and
kind of enthusiastically studied in the
middle ages and then refined
so for example uh planetary models of
ptolemy the greek astronomer from the
second century a.d
were studied and refined and then they
invented instruments
uh in order to try and model them they
invented instruments to model the
motions of the planets like
equatoria which are kind of planetary
computers
and then they try and kind of refine and
improve so the
the the spirit of the era is very much
to try to kind of tweak and improve
it's showing respect for the past and
then kind of
adding your own slant to it but when
they're what's what's motivating them is
it god
do they want to get closer to god
certainly somewhat yes so
people know if i'm worried that i'm
going to die from the plague i'm not
really thinking about the universe
so something's got to give them this
sort of free time
yeah but then you shouldn't worry about
dying from the plague because if you've
been a good person you're going to go to
heaven and that's much better than
anything that's on earth anyway right so
i forgot about that
don't worry about that um but absolutely
they wanted to get closer to god and
they
uh it was universally understood that
there were two ways
of understanding god one way of
understanding god was of course to read
the holy scriptures
the other way of understanding god was
to look at creation
and see that as evidence of god's work
in the world god's plan for the world
so for these people they literally
called them two books the book of
scripture and the book of nature
and nature was often after the invention
of the clock the mechanical clock which
is a key
invention of the later middle ages uh
you know without clocks we've got
nothing we've got no gps
we've got no um you know precise time
keeping
none of that and many of you people
didn't have gps
no apparently not no no no but they
didn't have maps maps
improve a lot in the later middle ages
uh maps map making is a really
interesting
uh thing because it's both symbolic and
descriptive in a way that our maps are
purely descriptive so
uh we kind of know what we want out of a
map medieval people wanted lots of
different things out of their maps
but that's another thing again i i is
here be dragons just uh fiction
there is one you you occasionally do get
well
explain here be dragons because maybe
not everyone has poured over
medieval maps and looked at the the
edges of the map
yeah that for me is the stereotype of
any medieval map of
uh it's got heavy ink stains and then in
one corner that's where the dragons are
yeah there there's one there's one map
that i think says
uh here are lions there is a famous
world map
called the hereford mapamundi which is
in hereford cathedral in england which
says these are dragons
um in on an island in the red sea
and also that map has uh salamander
which was kind of a mythical beast that
was believed to
live in fire and kind of get get energy
from from
living in fire um but the kind of the
interesting thing about that is that
that map
was in hereford cathedral because it was
intended to inspire pilgrims
so we shouldn't think of it as a map
that's like how to get from a to b
this is more like a kind of pictorial
history of a providential
universe so basically it shows bible
stories
kind of superimposed onto a very sort of
schematic
map of of the world so you shouldn't
it's just like trying to use your kids
picture atlas of the world that has like
you know
um foods from every country inside the
outline of that country you won't you
don't want to use that to get from a to
b
and these maps also were kind of aids to
contemplation but they did also have
navigational maps increasingly
in the late middle ages when the compass
comes in the compass magnetic compass
increasingly used for navigation
in the later middle ages as well i owned
quite a few old maps and i never fully
put two and two together
the older the map the more other crap
information it has on the map
it's just there's you know all manner of
illustrations
and it's like an entertaining um it's
like
you can you can make a board game out of
it or something it's just what it's for
it's like the difference between a road
map and a hiking map right
you know you don't need your road map to
show you where the interesting trees are
or the hills even
and you don't need your hiking map to
tell you about the speed limit on the
roads or where the speed counts are
and so the map serves a purpose every
map serves a purpose and it's the same
of course as different projections which
many listeners will know about the
mercator projection or the or the gold
peter's projection or different
projections
they all serve a different purpose no
one is necessarily better than any
others
um but they they have different um
benefits and drawbacks yeah that's a
lost
art actually i mean today a map is just
i gotta get to grandma's house you know
and so there it is turn left at the red
light and you're there
we gotta take a quick break when we come
back uh more
on medieval science the the truth
the untold truth about medial science
with seb fault we'll be right back
we're back causing aquarius star talk
we're talking about medieval science
apparently
there was science in medieval time and
seb fox
knows this and wrote a whole book on it
called the light ages
see what he did there the light ages the
surprising story of medieval science
coming out just just this year 2020. and
so seb
tell me about monasteries as
institutions and what role they played
monasteries of course were intended as
places where people could
study holy scripture could get closer to
god could take themselves out of
a kind of mundane day-to-day existence
and
seclude themselves from the world and
study and pray
but that studying included studying
god's creation
so there was always science happening in
monasteries because in order to try and
understand god
they underst they had to um they had to
kind of understand creation they had to
study
uh what god had done in the world now
before you mention this concept of two
books
galileo mentions two books when he
refers to
he said uh in my worldview
uh god wrote two books one the
scriptures
and one how the world works which which
then leads to the fun
uh quote attributed to him but i think
it's to someone else
the bible tells you how to go to heaven
not how the heavens go
so i always enjoyed that that quote but
it does
it's an implicit reference to these two
uh uh
pathways of inquiry but go on and people
in the middle ages were quite used to
reading the bible allegorically right
we think of biblical literalism as being
kind of an old thing actually it's a
very new thing that people like
fundamentalist christians
are a new phenomenon people in the
middle ages were quite happy
to read the bible as being uh figurative
if it conflicted with
their experience and you know great
theologians like said augustine say
if an infidel if somebody who's not a
christian knows more about science than
you listen to them
because you don't want to bring
christianity into disrepute
by saying um you're wrong this is what
it says in the bible and then turns out
that you're wrong and you make the bible
look silly so saint augustine is
as if i remember correctly he shaped a
lot of what we think of as modern
christianity right absolutely
yeah put together pieces to make it a
religion as opposed to the the cult
following that jesus had
in his day and he popularizes this idea
that um infidel knowledge which
uh later comes to include the great
greek philosopher aristotle
was was like egyptian gold he called it
and that's a reference to the story of
the israelites who flee out of egypt and
they steal a lot of the gold from egypt
when they leave
and that's okay because they're kind of
putting it to good use
so they're taking this gold and they're
putting it to a better use than the
egyptians would have done
and that's all right and in the same way
using this
um kind of science that was uh created
by pagans like the ancient greeks
was okay for christians if they could
use it to convince other people of the
glory of god
so studying nature was absolutely
practiced and endorsed in the
monasteries
and what happens is that the monasteries
they get wealthy
they get lots of books they either copy
books or people give them books
and they spend a lot of time on their
hands right so
they spend a lot of time studying these
books and then what happens is the
universities the foundation of the great
universities
in the 12th century and in the 13th
century means that
suddenly there's kind of a another
center for people to study learning and
scholarship and then the monasteries
kind of lose a little bit of that
importance as people go to universities
instead yeah but all the
all the first universities so many of
them had
theological foundations right where
that's the only organized anything
in a society are the religious orders
well there were okay
there were three higher subjects that
you could study at university theology
law and medicine but in order before you
do any of those three subjects
you have to study the the seven liberal
arts and the seven liberal arts were the
three arts of the word which is logic
grammar and rhetoric so arts of making
yourself understood and convincing
uh an audience and then the four arts of
number
um which were um arithmetic
astronomy geometry and music we think of
music that doesn't really fit in but of
course music is all about harmonic
ratios and things particularly for
people
in the middle ages so music is like
applied arithmetic to them
and astronomy is applied geometry so
astronomy is
all about making models that explain how
the heavens go
in fact for men for more than a century
astronomy
learning astronomy was based in the math
departments of
of universities so that that
juxtaposition is real and one last thing
before we go to q a
tell me about the transition from roman
numerals to arabic numerals
that's a really interesting one because
the arabic did that happen under your
watch i mean
yeah more or less so so the the arabic
numerals
uh kind of misnamed in a way because
they come out of india originally
um and they come out of uh india in
about the kind of
sixth seventh century we don't exactly
know when and they're picked up
in um the islamic world in the kind of
eighth ninth century
and then they come to europe in about
the 11th 12th century
um but they kind of picked up graduates
that's pretty slow-moving
i mean yeah well the point is this right
it's that's pretty slow
i can walk that distance in less time
yeah but this is pre-broadband they were
like dial-up
at best but again it's
why change why change if it works for
you right you know
i'm i'm really slow to streaming because
i have a perfectly good dvd player
right dvd works for me i don't get
streaming and i'm quite able to watch
the same dvd's
what is it what's a dvd player uh it's
like uh it's like a
video tape set if your kids mess around
with it
it doesn't work anymore i think that's
true for videotapes as well
but anyway um i have a lot of scratch
dvds at home because i have small
children
um but uh but basically if it works then
why
why change it if they broke don't fix it
and that's kind of the attitude in the
middle ages right they're quite happy
with roman numerals and as i explained
in the book
it's not as hard as you might think to
multiply roman numerals if you have a
system
and you practice it and they there were
various systems that they could use one
of them was called kind of the russian
peasant method by some people but
it's practiced in different parts of the
world and involves basically turns
multiplication into a series of
doublings and halvings which you can
more or less do in your head
so it doesn't matter about the roman
numerals being um
not place value that's the problem with
roman numerals is that you don't have
the place value the columns
that we have in hindu arabic numerals so
they come in astronomers
are the first people to use the hindu
arabic numerals because they're the ones
that are doing the really yeah there we
are
there we are people you can get on board
with something here the astronomers are
doing the biggest maths right they are
calculating
to like nine sexy decimal places this is
billions upon billions right so the
sexagesimo system is base 60
so they're working in base 60 because of
course that's um
how it makes degrees easy because the
360 degrees in a circle
we use base60 still of course for hours
minutes and seconds
um that is a base 60 system and the
astronomers are routinely so the hours
are not basically
but the minutes and seconds are yeah
sure but there are 16 minutes in an hour
and 60 seconds in a
in a minute but they're not 60 hours in
anything
yeah but they do they do come up with
tables actually that um
have 60 days as well so they do uh they
do it that way
as well so if they try and make it work
as much for them as possible and they do
60th of a day rather than
hours and so on um so they try and make
it as easy to calculate as possible but
those are the people that need to do the
hindu arabic numerals because for that
kind of level of calculation
they need to make it much much easier
very cool
all right so matt start start to start
us off here also questions
yeah so these questions are all from
patreon and this dovetails very neatly
into
the question from cody klobuski which is
how important were the cosmos in
medieval times and what type of uses and
discoveries were made
well that's where the real science was
taking place right
was looking up at the stars and the
reason was because the stars were
susceptible to precise measurement
you could measure the exact magnitude of
an eclipse or you could measure
the angles between a star on the horizon
or you could measure the angles between
two planets in the sky
you could precisely time when the sun
was going to rise and you could work out
where on the horizon
the sun was going to rise so all of
these things are susceptible to precise
measurements so it's really super
scientific
the other thing is that pretty much
everybody in the middle ages
believed that the stars affected what
happened down here on earth
astrology pretty much and that kind of
has a logical underpinning in the sense
that
the sun heats the earth the moon affects
the tides
and if those things are happening then
why shouldn't the planets
also affect um what's happening down
here on earth so everything's
a dose of human hubris that the whole
universe knows about you
i mean that's just yeah i mean a
universe created by god
and and very much that everything um
that the humans are a microcosm of this
heavenly macrocosm
so basically um humans are made of
elements
uh the four elements the four classical
elements earth air
fire and water and those are
representatives i thought it was i
thought it was earth wind and fire
um all right so seb on your next edition
of the book
just get it correct this time earth wind
fire plus a rhythm section
those are the elements we're made of
okay absolutely there was a whole debate
about this right
in the middle ages of course it's a
mistake to think that people in the
middle ages thought the earth was flat
they didn't
but they did operate on the basic
principle that the natural place of
earth
was inside water and the natural place
of water was inside air the natural
place of air was inside fire
and that makes sense if you drop a stone
in the ocean it sinks right
but if uh the earth is inside the water
why are we not under water why haven't
we drowned if the sphere of earth is
inside the sphere of water
why are we above water and this was a
question that was debated a lot in the
universities
because there was not a water layer
between earth and the air exactly the
earth touched the air
so i mean it's kind of it's not a
question that bothers astronomers right
astronomers are not
like they're more interested in looking
up at the stars and they can they can
measure the size of the earth without
worrying about
the sphere of water but they do some
philosophers
wonder whether maybe the sphere of water
has been displaced
so that the southern hemisphere is
entirely underwater and that's why us in
the northern hemisphere
are above water and this is something
that's debated a little bit in the
middle particularly
just in the in the 15th century um when
people
kind of start to ask this sort of
question but most people just say
actually you know mountains poke up
above the water what's the big deal
and also the elements can change into
one another so you know it's happening
it's changing all the time for these
people
um but yeah so humans are made of
elements so we have these four humors
um blood phlegm black bile
and yellow bile and those still are in
our own language today right when people
talk about being sanguine or being
phlegmatic or melancholy
those words uh that we still use today
are kind of humoral theory and that's to
say that
the composition of these humors in your
body affects
your well-being and it can affect your
mood and if it affects you
you even say he's good humored we'll say
that right that's
exactly that's a perfectly common phrase
right yeah yeah absolutely
um and and of course this one of the one
of the things about medieval medicine
was it's all about maintaining a balance
right you've got to think about going to
a doctor
as being more like going to a physio
today if you're an athlete
that you have a kind of an ongoing
relationship with your physio and they
stop you getting ill in the first place
rather than just always curing you
nowadays we tend to only go and see a
doctor unless you know maybe
if you're above a certain age and you
can have a regular checkup but
most people who are healthy most of the
time only go and see a doctor when they
get ill
but in the middle ages it was more about
maintaining a relationship with your
physician which of course is very good
for your physician financially
and and one of the things they do is
they balance your humors right which
for men often meant bloodletting meant
taking blood out of your body
um because it was the imbalance that was
thought to cause
disease there not so much a problem with
women because they bleed monthly anyway
so
but there were all kinds of beliefs
about what um that might cause and how
that might
um be regulated naturally so um
it was it was a kind of an interesting
world but basically what happens
is that the cosmos is affecting what's
down here below so so the heavens the
planets
clearly affect the weather because the
weather is is the elements when we talk
about the elements
we talk about we're talking about the
weather even today
um you know in casualty i mean um and
and if if the planets can affect
your humors in your body then they can
also affect your mood because you know
let's face it if you get hungry and you
get angry then
that's your your makeup of your body
your chemicals
it's called hangry exactly there we are
so
uh so then what happens is actually
people's behavior can be affected by the
heavens
so there's a kind of a logic to it um
okay that's that helps me out here
because i kept if i think about them as
disparate
constructs it's like what wtf right but
if they all
come together in this sort of and what's
interesting is that like the intuitive
knowledge of a lot of these people can
be sometimes ahead
of the philosophers right so galileo has
this great theory of the tides
which is part of for him um supporting
his theory
that the earth spins because of course
the earth has to spin if they haven't
done them spin
um and he says that the tides are caused
by the earth spinning
like imagine if you're in your bath and
you're kind of kids are in the bath and
they're like sloshing the water and you
get these waves in the bath
that's what's happening for galileo
right but the genuine
general understanding of the tides is
actually much better like your average
sailor
knew when the tides were high and when
the tides were low and on a monthly
basis they might not be able to predict
high tide and low tide to the nearest
minute
but they could do it to the nearest hour
um so so you know they understood the
effect of the moon on the tides better
sometimes than the philosophers
because they're they were active daily
observers of it exactly right so they
were
naturally empirical yeah we got to take
another break and when we come back
more of cosmic queries the science or
absence thereof of it
in the middle ages with subfloor we'll
be right back
we're back star talk i'm literally tyson
matt kirschen always good to have you
dude
it's nice to be here you're tweeting at
matt curtin that's that's where i am
if you don't know the spelling like what
do you what do you put
oh it's on twitter it's just an amazing
feed oh it's it's pure quality there's
there's no there's no fat whatsoever on
my twitter bread
it's just gem after
[Music]
it's a weird enough name that you'll
find me it'll find you and how about you
seb are you on social media i am at sev
underscore
fork and lots of pretty pictures of
medieval manuscripts and you know
instruments and people doing weird stuff
in the middle ages
riding off their own testicles and
unicorns and all kinds of stuff like
that
wow that's a new one i'll tell you all
about it yeah yeah
just just to be clear um in a medieval
time
all books were themselves manuscripts
right they were right the printing press
had not yet been invented so
everything is hand scribed absolutely so
if you want a copy of something you've
probably got to make it yourself
how old are you how old are your kids uh
six and three
okay the six-year-old show your
six-year-old
how good the penmanship was of these
people
800 years ago and because the penmanship
has gone to hell at least in the united
states i don't know what it is in the uk
so just give just just make them give
them something to aspire to
by showing them especially the
illuminated first letters of pages
well this is it right some of the time
um i have to say to people
you've seen these beautiful illuminated
medieval manuscripts right the ones that
are in kind of
sell for millions and millions of
dollars and kind of are in
exhibitions in art galleries all the
time and the ones i look at are not
always like that the ones i look at
other kind of science
books and just as uh you know science
books today are not always the most
beautiful things to look at
um so they weren't in the middle ages
either so often they were very
utilitarian they're full of tables
interesting little sketchy diagrams but
not beautifully decorated
um and there's a mix of all those in my
book so lots of this
i think 65 illustrations so you get
interesting so illustrated
very good very good how would i fare as
a scientist if i were dropped into
medieval times because i thought i'd be
king of that domain based on my
not previous assumptions about their
uh lack of advanced knowledge
well i mean a lot of a lot of the stuff
that we um
take for granted they were incredible
with right calculation
spherical trigonometry is not a thing
that's taught in schools today but to be
an astronomer in the middle ages
you had to understand your your
spherical trigonometry really well
um and so an understanding of latitude
and longitude
three-dimensional understanding as well
right astronomers worked in horizontal
coordinates so that's above the horizon
and along the horizon
they worked in equatorial coordinates
right ascension and uh
declination and they worked in ecliptic
coordinates
uh longitudinal attitude according to
the path of the sun through the stars
across the year
so they're working in three dimensions
and three planes it's pretty good so
matt
nice try nice try yeah i'd be screwed
i'd be done
all right so again let's see how many
questions we can get in this segment
yeah so i'm going to combine two
different questions here because they're
in the same
but if you want to hear their names so
uh evan of abraham
and chris hampton have both asked
questions about
the primitive nature of medieval science
and how primitive our present science
would look to future generations
uh for example chris says perhaps the
way we smash atoms together will be seen
as barbaric
if adam's had feelings i guess and
up says how far in the future would we
consider today's tools as medieval or
obsolete
yeah that's a good one i mean it's a
it's a good question i can't predict
what's going to happen in the future but
i think one of the things that's really
important
is uh when we belittle the past when we
belittle people in the middle ages it's
often because we assume that we know
everything now
and real scientists will tell you that
that's not the case you know science has
never finished science is never going to
finish
there'll always be more questions to ask
and so and if this year has taught us
anything
it's that science has its limitations
right that there are certain things that
science can't do even though of course
you know the production of a vaccine for
covert has been incredibly impressive
there are still certain you know ways
that nature can take us by surprise
and yeah and sev i you know when that
when the world health organization said
pandemic i'm thinking
no can't be a pandemic that's for like
long ago people
to have pandemics that's even a question
that sherry lynn
sk asks which is what lessons can we
learn from medieval science to help us
through the current pandemic
yeah because they themselves had some
pandemics right so absolutely
yeah i mean they they usually you're
bloodletting that
well i mean uh i would say one of the
lessons
is is is not a lesson that i would like
people to take away which is don't trust
the
scientists because often the uh the the
experts
in um the middle ages were just as
uh just as blind as everybody else um
but uh but it has to be said that a lot
of the measures that were taken in the
middle ages against the black death
are a lot like the ones taken today
people wearing masks
people social distancing uh you know not
letting people out of certain cities if
there was a case of the plagues that
kind of quarantines and things
but then cities have walls so you could
actually do that yeah absolutely
or not letting people in so um all a lot
of the measures that
people are talking about today were
tried in the middle ages as well
um but of course uh the sort of
theoretical understanding was was on a
very different level
right plus you can't see the culprit
right
you know if it's a microscopic element
so at least today only some people
are saying that there's some divine
wrath
and but back then that would have been
everybody's assumption right if you've
got
you got the plague misbehaved yesterday
right it was it was one explanation
right but i think one of the things
that's really important to say about the
middle ages is people don't all believe
the same thing all the time
so there's lots of different competing
explanations and those do compete in a
kind of a scientific marketplace
right so you've got people saying it's
like by astrology it's caused by a
planetary conjunction
because mars and jupiter and saturn all
came together in 1345
and this caused the plague there are
other people saying yes it's the wrath
of god and we've all got to repent for
our sins
there are other people talking about
much more mundane explanations
like um bad air pollution bad water
some people say it's caused by poisoning
there's some people who blame the jews
unfortunately
and and kind of scapegoat them for for
poisoning wells and so on so there's
lots of different competing explanations
and you get people writing at the time
about you know which of these are more
plausible than others and who can we
trust
and correct my memory if if
if i'm wrong weren't there women who
were suspected of
sorcery or so witchery uh because
many
women unmarried women living living
alone
had cats and the cats would eat
the mice and the rats that would
otherwise be the vectors of
plague and so you had this community of
women who owned cats
who didn't get sick while everyone
around them was getting sick
and so this would implicate them in
sorcery or some kind of
there is that story that goes around
clearly they're witches
and that's why i don't think it's very
widespread i'm afraid it's a really nice
story
uh and it might have happened in one
place but it's not it's not a big it's
not a big story because
okay how are people gonna notice you
know that that
that like the cat is is linked it's not
you know the level of epidemiology is
not on that level
so you're not also able to notice but
and also
the time of witchcraft and which trials
that's later
later it's not really a medieval thing
but how about muslims who
where uh ritual cleaning is multiple
times a day so that
the general out of just what's
prescribed in the quran
so that the general hygiene is higher
among muslims so if you have this plague
running through town and the muslim
community does not catch it
and you don't know it's because of their
their their
cleansing rituals then you could end up
blaming them as well right people
looking for stuff to blame if you don't
know what the real answer is
i mean again it doesn't it doesn't
happen a huge amount because unlike
jewish communities where there were
established jewish communities in a lot
of towns across europe there weren't
many muslims apart from in
in spain and there wasn't a huge amount
i mean there was some mixing
so there weren't muslim pockets within
other communities
all right so so i was just thinking uh
if you brought someone from your time
your
your your people and bring them to
modern times
and they say look we have a plague today
we call it a pandemic
and they said wow um show me the
hospitals and things so you go to the
hospitals and there's you know
and then there's a whole section where
people are giving blood
oh you're still there bloodletting are
right we're just capturing it in a
bucket now um
well i i'm gonna that sort of backs into
a couple of questions about
the advancement of science i'm gonna
again combine two one from
tom bock and one from jason because
they're in the same field
so tom asks when contemplating all the
things that were discovered in medieval
science
what do you believe was the most ahead
of its time discovery or the one thing
that could be deemed as simply
incredible they were able to discover
given the limits of their tools
and then jason asks jason's a truck
driver
and says i drive a large box equipped
with a first aid kit fire extinguisher
and roadside emergency kit
but if my truck was somehow to travel
back to the middle ages in whose
backyard would you hope it landed in and
what things might they be able to
reverse engineer or apply to their
current understanding of science
oh gosh cool question you know that
that's you know that uh what's the guy's
name with who drives the truck just
jason
yeah jason should should write a good a
sci-fi time travel knowledge
that'll be good what was it what was
there in his truck in your aim so
we've got a first aid kit a fire
extinguisher and a roadside emergency
kit
and then obviously the the general
mechanisms of a truck yeah absolutely i
mean i think people in the
in the middle ages they were really
obsessed with gadgets and they would
have been really interested in the
combustion engine
they would have been interested just to
see how everything fitted together
and how everything was incredibly smooth
because on their terms you know they're
dealing with problems like that
the mechanical clock was probably the
most impressive innovation
of the middle ages that perhaps along
with advances in lenses that spectacles
because glasses spectacles
were invented in the middle ages as well
and without the invention of the
spectacles
you know the telescope at the beginning
of the 17th century couldn't have
happened right so
it's the understanding of magnification
that's developed even if the lens
grinding techniques aren't quite there
yet so this community of curious people
are the ones he should
drop his truck off yeah park his truck
in front of that those flyers or those
kinds of people right because friars
they've got the kind of interest in
scholarship that the monks had but they
move around so they kind of come into
contact with more
more knowledge and more understanding
given the mystical tandem beliefs would
he be
viewed as some kind of a demon to be
shunned and maybe even killed i think
he'd have to just say the right thing i
mean
there's no people wouldn't automatically
to the conclusion that he was a demon i
think people well wait if there's a fire
going off and he goes with his
co2 extinguisher boom fire's gone
oh my gosh he would be the god among men
you possibly or he would be as a uh
hear that jason right you got that oh he
might he might be seen as a kind of
devil washer right because
this is what is often said about devil
worshipers that they make smoke right
they make smoke it's all smoke and
mirrors right they kind of
they they they mutter incantations and
then smoke rises and this is how they
uh they bring out the devil so
he's got to get his excusing clearly
first and then and then he'll be fine
um so based on which based on what
you've said i would
vote then that the mechanical geared
clock is one of the great
inventions coming out of that period and
i mean and that goes into a lot of
things right
milling really effective milling cranks
and camshafts are kind of engineering
type stuff also engineering solutions
that allow
the building of the great cathedrals and
the fact that the romans had such
great urban engineering that they didn't
come up with a mechanical clock that's
an interesting fact to me
yeah um but again it's about the
um the desire for these things right
because these clocks you know the
there's the desire to kind of um have
some kind of an automaton
uh a device that will beat out an equal
amount of time
in it you know in equal amounts of time
exactly in
good amounts of time uh but then they go
beyond this right so you've got this
monk richard of wallingford who got
leprosy
uh he was he was abbot of said albans in
the 1330s
and he invented this mechanical clock
and it didn't just tell the time it told
three different kinds of time it told
the canonical hours which are kind of
seasonal hours which change in length at
different times of the year
but the mean hours which is what we use
today and the true hours
which are a time that changes at
different times of year
so this clock could show you that the
true time which is something clocks
today even don't show
um and uh and then it could also show
you the phases of the moon and the
height of tides and all kinds of
different things so that's why i think
that they would have
been um really interested in seeing the
combustion engine because that would
have just been
like an incredible piece of gear right
so it's not just science it's it's
emergent engineering so yeah that's good
but then that wouldn't have scared them
in this like because i think a sort of
an iphone or a computer would be just
baffling but
you can look into a combustion engine
and there's nothing in there that
doesn't
rely on science that they already
understand it's just fire and movement
well exactly that's why i think that
they will be most impressed by it and a
mystery liquid too
there's a mystery liquid that makes it
happen right yeah
so matt we got to go into like lightning
round here so let's see how many
questions
and so so seb you we need two or three
sentence answers pretend you're on the
evening news
and the only one is sound bites okay go
man all right phillip dewind from
belgium says what are your personal
favorite discoveries and what do you
hope we will discover in the future that
will help humanity
uh i i really love the um animal myths
and legends right the bestiaries like
um the idea that you can tame a unicorn
by taking a virgin into the woods and a
unicorn will put its head in her lap
and i like them the idea that beavers
get away from hunters by biting off
their testicles and throwing them in the
hunters faces
i love that kind of stuff uh and how is
that going to help us in the future it's
not
but i think it's important that we
maintain
that medieval sense of wonder i think
it's really important that we maintain a
kind of sense that in the world
amazing incredible things happen and
they're out there for us to discover
okay all right next right toby
sonnenberg says
are there any textbook famous scientists
whose discoveries were actually
rediscoveries because a previous
scientist had had their work forgotten
or unacknowledged
uh well that's a that's a great question
um
there were quite a lot of rediscoveries
in the later middle ages
where um medieval people rediscovered
the
what were thought to be lost works of
ancient uh
thinkers like aristotle and euclid
and um ptolemy the astronomer
and then kind of pick them up again and
those are you know have a massive make
an enormous impact
on on scholarship in the later middle
ages
uh will brion says is science intuitive
to our species in other words is it
natural for young children and
pre-evolution humans to logically think
through a problem
to find a solution if so why is the
spread of misinformation so common now
it seems like people should be using
more logic
man that sounds like he's accusing seb
of this or something
i think it is i think people people are
really interested in understanding the
world around them
and people always ask questions about
you know why is this thing happening the
rainbow is a classic example right
explanations for the rainbow go right
through human history and attempts to
understand the rainbow attempts to
categorize the colors
attempts to kind of work out how it
works the combination of reflection and
refraction in water droplets
that's something that gets a lot of
intense study in the middle ages
um and so people are always asking these
questions about nature
but then i think people now as then
are susceptible to groupthink and just
uh you know
picking up what they're told and not
trusting uh you know not trusting the
right people or trusting the wrong
people
and and i think that can sometimes
override our natural
uh sense of questioning and ingenuity
okay so it's different to say
we have a natural sense of wonder about
the natural world that's different from
my ability to explain it is also
logically constructed because these are
two different sides of the coin that we
are
the wonder side and then what's my
account of that wonder
and one can be spiritual supernatural
the other could be
uh um scientific or
and the other thing you have to have for
science is a sense that your explanation
is going to be good for somebody else as
well right is this universality
uh and that was something that people
kind of were
not so sure about in the middle ages
that they they didn't think that
knowledge
was necessarily transferable so it's
you're on safer ground with logic you're
on safer ground by saying
i believe that every motion in the
heavens is in a perfect circle
on that basis we can logically predict
this is how the universe is going to
work
and that logic is very strong but of
course if your premises don't hold up
then um then it leads you to false
conclusions
matt time for one last question make it
a good one all right i like this one
from sriram govindan if we were to look
at major scientific discoveries made in
the past
do we see any pattern can we predict
when the next one is likely to be made
also what is the major trigger for such
discoveries war seclusion
education system wow so i would broaden
that not just i probably as
the he intends not single discoveries
but
periods of time and place where you have
great fertility
of creative thinking i mean
communication
humans talking to each other is the is
the impetus for great discoveries
and we see that in the european middle
ages when they pick up ideas
from the islamic world and we see that
in the islamic world when they pick up
ideas
from the ancient greeks and it's this
desire to kind of learn from other other
cultures
one of the myths about the middle east
to contest your ideas right because
maybe you have an idea
and if you have another idea that
contested well wait let's figure this
out
and that's another sort of motivation
there yeah yeah and that was that's why
that's why the medieval universities
were so important because that was a
place where they brought in ideas from
different places and they said hold on
aristotle conflicts with what we believe
about biblical creation what's going on
here
or this islamic thinker conflicts with
what we thought about the motions of the
heavens and and can we
reconcile them and if we can't reconcile
them who's right and who's wrong so the
more
ideas you throw into the mix the more we
communicate the more
um things advance and that to me is the
key
and i think wasn't there a pact during
the second world war among
warring factions that no one would bomb
each other's universities
i mean i heard this yeah i mean i think
it does seem
universities did often get off lightly
but i think it's mainly because the
priority was to bomb the industry
so university like oxford for example
got bombed cambridge didn't
because oxford had big motor factories
so
you know i think it was more about the
priorities right okay
all right listen guys i think we have to
call it quits there but seb this is this
is brilliant i love it
you got a book out hopefully set the
record straight um
and but it is true no i don't want to go
back and live then
just if no no offense no no but you can
still be interested in it right
people the old the old says the old
saying is the past is a foreign country
right and anything yeah that's true
then it's why not be a tourist for a bit
why not go and hang out in the middle
ages
see what they're doing play with an
astrolade and um
and have a good time get a novelty
pencil with a name of it on the side
you're gonna do all the tourist things
matt always good to have you dude
it's a pleasure to be here thanks for
having me don't don't be such a stranger
and said we'll get we'll get back to you
again yeah
there is so much more there's lots more
history of science so much more all
right
neil degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist as always beating you
to keep
you